just working don't go for your gun right
here at this time
you're behind the curb okay but this way
i guess
if you're gonna if you're gonna see
distance right
then it shouldn't be a coq projection
and not a push
so i'm not going to
don't contest right here
okay let's go we're gonna take the gu
aspect out of it
okay so she's gonna come in i'm gonna
seek this contact here
so she's coming in i'm going to catch
the wrist and the elbow
and there's there's my ik adhesion
and then i'll come up top pull the puck
here okay
and then i'll draw my weapon
so key is you're not just slapping it
out of the way
and you're not just moving out of the
way i have to send her that way
so contact boom so with your adhesion
you do that
don't do it with your wrap don't do it
with the crab
okay not even this grab here
just keep keep the thing going boom pop
and then you have your that's that's
gonna be the first
technique
okay let's try okay this one goes to the
inside here
here's my contact point okay so my
adhesion is here
so here and here but with a stripe
okay and then i move to the other
there's only sanctuary that i'm
well this is no different knife away
you give your hands this is no different
than this okay
it's just my contact point let go my
contact points are here
oh here
there's not enough fish to hit them i'm
gonna get hit
maybe i don't have the effect on their
consciousness so
sure boom and forget
okay